cuéntenos el gobierno de eeuu ha
impuesto sanciones contra varios
funcionarios cubanos esto ayudará
realmente la situación en la isla es una
medida que aporta al esfuerzo que está
haciendo la población cual en este
momento
yo diría que las sanciones que se han
establecido algunos funcionarios del
gobierno y también a la policía y a la
organización de la brigada de respuestas
rápidas los llamados
boinas buenas negras son más bien gestos
simbólicos porque estas personas y esta
instituciones ya están sancionadas
debido al embargo establecido en la isla
pero si en el ambiente actual
contribuyen a dar la impresión de que el
gobierno de eeuu efectivamente está
poniendo presión sobre el gobierno de
cuba para que respete el derecho a las
demostraciones pacíficas y a la
disidencia bueno por otro lado dice voto
en eeuu una resolución para que el
gobierno va a ir en garantice el
internet a los ciudadanos cubanos
considera usted que de esto posible y de
qué manera se podría lograr para que así
el gobierno cubano no paralizar estos
apagones de internet que se han vuelto
acostumbrados
el tema de internet ha salido a la
discusión pública desde que el gobierno
cubano decidió interrumpir el servicio
el mismo 11 de julio para no permitir
que siguieran circulando las imágenes de
los textos a través del mundo de la de
las manifestaciones como la que estamos
viendo en este momento pero después de
un mes tal parece que las dificultades
técnicas de cómo llevar a cabo esta
transmisión o esta apertura de internet
por parte de compañías privadas
estadounidenses parecería ser que a
pesar de la voluntad del interés del
gobierno de estados unidos y también de
buena parte del público
estadounidense y sobre todo el
cubanoamericano es muy difícil que se
ponga en práctica este tipo de solución
a menos que el gobierno cubano no fuera
a colaborar con este esfuerzo bueno y
por último cuéntenos en qué ha cambiado
la situación de los cubanos a partir del
11 de julio se sabe que el gobierno ha
permitido por ejemplo el ingreso de
alimentos elementos de aseo por la
aduana de los principales aeropuertos
pero también que continúa la represión y
que continúan muchos jóvenes
desaparecidos cuéntanos a usted en qué
ha mejorado o empeorado la situación en
cuba
pero el otro cambio que se ha anunciado
esta semana ha sido la legalización de
las pequeñas empresas medianas y
microempresas un cambio que ya se había
autorizado previamente pero que
finalmente se hace ley pero fuera de
estas dos medidas junto con la
aprobación de la importación de
medicinas y comida el libre impuesto
realmente ha cambiado muy poco ha habido
pocas respuestas a parte de la represión
de las manifestaciones por parte del
gobierno cubano y efectivamente todavía
quedan decenas de personas detenidas o
desaparecidas o que han sido
expuestas a juicios sumarios yo pienso
que ningún gobierno autoritario o
democrático puede continuar ignorando
una expresión tan contundente de puntos
de vista distintos al gobierno como lo
que ha ocurrido a partir del 8 de julio
así que tarde o temprano y esperemos que
sea más temprano que tarde el gobierno
cubano tendrá que sentarse a la mesa y
discutir con algunos de los sectores
representativos de estas múltiples voces